hello my name is matt and you're
watching code attacking tutorials my
youtube channel about code tech and uh
tutorials
yeah
we're going to look at shared pointers
today and some examples of how to use
them so we're going to be going over
just the core concepts of them and a
uh what the thousand or ten thousand
foot view of how
they should typically be used and what
they're
uh brought in to solve because in
general if you're bringing something new
into your code it's to solve some sort
of problem and the problem here that you
typically want to solve is
shared ownership but sometimes there can
be a case
where you have something that comes into
scope
and a bunch of different things may or
may not want to use it
and as long as something is using it you
want it to stay alive and stay in memory
and then when nothing is using it
and all the people that were working
with it are done with it it goes out of
scope and it deallocates
and thus
basically manages itself
all you have to do is
say who's using it at the moment
basically
so we're going to look at examples and
syntax that involve the shared pointer
and how to use it here i have a new
project i launched with the visual
studio
or c plus plus
and i picked the cmake pattern not that
that really matters too much but it gave
us some boilerplate code that says hello
cmake
and we are going to want to include
memory because that is where shared
pointers are as well so i like to do
examples that involve
some kind of thing you would encounter
in real life because i feel like those
are easier for people to understand
so this often works well with maybe a
small sample of the simulation so let's
make a dog
that
potentially
goes to different places
and the and maybe we'll we'll throw a
cat in there too maybe a dog and a cat
it'll be like be like ren and stimpy
all right so let's make some structs for
those objects so we're gonna make a dog
and uh what do you want to know about a
dog maybe it's has a hunger level float
and well that's kind of a weird thing to
start out with maybe we want a type of a
dog or let's just go with size and we'll
store that as a float as well all right
so we're just going to stick with a dog
for now we're going to make the most
simple example possible let's say we
have another construct called a
place
which will simulate
a place in the world or like a
point of interest we might say
and for here we want to know about
potential dogs we could even store an
array of these we're gonna just store it
as a shared pointer the dogs are going
to be in a place called a let's do the
kennel let's say we're making a kennel
set up instead of just
one dog
the kennel can store
a whole bunch of dogs as many as you
want so we'll use the vector memory type
and now we are also getting into
something called data oriented design
but we'll save that particular thing for
another time all right so shared pointer
a dog a whole vector of them dogs have a
weight and a hunger level maybe we'll
also throw in here just age
all right very good
so
now we want to run a simulation and use
these shared pointers
now this is going to work a little
better if we have other things that the
dog would want to be shared with so
let's try to come up with some you know
what let's just make a vet veterinarian
because maybe they both belong to the
kennel and the veterinarian like maybe a
sick one came into the kennel so still
registered there but they want to send
it to the vet for a while then when it's
done into the vet it goes back to
whoever's left on the list of owners
which would be the kennel but we could
in theory have a people owner too or
something in this case
like we could have a
human
and then we could have in here
you know maybe you'd want to expand it
to more pets we could have a vector of
shared pointer dogs own or something
like that we could do all kinds of cool
c plus plus to expand this out to be
pets owned and then give them a type but
we're not worried about that here
i just you know all kinds of things come
up in my mind of ways to expand it
because c plus plus is fun isn't it guys
okay so there we got the kennel you know
and i was just thinking dogs probably
need a name
so let's give each dog
a string
name so we're going to have to also
include string here
all right very good
so with this vet of course needs
a list of dogs too and they might store
associated data for the dogs like what's
wrong with them but we're not going to
worry about that we're just saying the
dog
can have multiple owners
and it could be owned by the kennel the
vet the human it could be owned by
several at once
uh but it you know because it might be
owned by a human but staying in the
kennel because the humans on vacation or
something but they'll still keep
ownership of it is the point and you'll
see that here shortly but when the
kennel releases it
there's only going to be one owner left
so all right let's just show some
examples i want to get into the syntax
and show the different ways to use this
shared pointer so first of all this is
all about the pups
support the doge
so we're going to make a shared pointer
of our main doge
and let's just call him charles because
charles is a great dog named now this
starts out empty so if we want to
initialize him we have to use
make shared so we'll
pick shared and then the type you're
making which is going to be a dog
in this case and then it wants all the
initialization details
now there are none because there's no
constructor here but we could assume
since it's a struct that it goes in
order so it could take name weight
hunger level age and let's maybe put
them in this order
it'd be better to just make an actual
constructor but
we're going to give them the name
charles
we're going to say he's 2
his weight i don't know let's say he's a
50 pound
dog
and then we need a hunger level
i guess we'll just put it at one
we haven't really defined how the hunger
works or anything it's just another
variable to play around with
and now another thing i should point out
that's probably a little awkward is we
already have his name stored so we
probably don't want to go off the
variable name too it's actually uh
going to make it hard to reason about
after a while so we're just going gonna
call this dog one
like that guy in the shiloh movie does
all right so we're gonna say
we're gonna see out dog one
uh and then to get to its data
you do the pointer thing to dereference
so that would that would show the name
and then we also could put an end line
here
so we should get just a name
into our console if everything's working
great so far
all right well the problem is it doesn't
like this whole thing and us doing this
whole thing down here so we actually
need to make constructor either that or
we don't want to get into more code so
we're just going to delete it
and now i'm just going to show you how
to change its details
you just set it
like so
dog one and then
you have access to all its members name
we'll set them equal to charles
charles the pup
or console outing the data should work
let's have a look and there it says
charles so we know that its base is
working now of course we want to set the
other things
like age here weight hunger level weight
i'm going to change hunger level to just
hunger of course these don't want to be
assigned strings let's stick to the same
he's about two point
f
that's two and flow i decided to stick
with floats there
because we can go like 2.5 i don't know
it might it's probably actually better
as an integer
but then
you got to keep track of the birthday to
increment and stuff right so maybe with
the float we can just increment it a
little bit as like half a year passes by
that's why i was kind of going to float
there
but uh you can do it however you want
there's his weight of 50. let's say you
gained a pound no particular reason why
51 pounds
dog
in his hunger level is one
now this should all work we could of
course console all this out too
but let's move on to the more
cool points and cool features of the
shared pointer
so first of all this is of course going
to stay in scope and to the end now
that's not really any different from a
normal pointer at this point we could
just call the dog pointer not use to
make sure
but
the whole passing it around is where
things get interesting a
kennel
a vet
and a human
maybe the human should have a name and
stuff i don't know doesn't matter
they're just things that could own the
dog right that's all we really care
about now what we can do is we can go
kennel.pushback
or kennel.dogs
to add
another dog to their list
but if we add it as a shared pointer is
essentially signing
another sharepointer of the same type
this variable
and when you do an assignment
it keeps the control block the same
essentially each shared pointer only has
one control block the only thing that
gets passed around and duplicated is
pointers
and it automatically manages that
reference count for you
so we're going to see ways to play
around with that but first of all let's
go ahead
and
just add
dog one to this
and
this is going to add
basically via an assignment operator
dog one
so you can pass these by value now this
isn't a function
but is essentially
going to be
pretty similar in that we're passing
this by value
because this wants it also by
the shared pointer value
so now we could say something like
panel dot
dogs needs to know which one
a we'll just say the first one with
front
name
and then
we should see that
we should see the exact same dog charles
and charles now what normally happens
when you're not using a shared pointer
here and you're just using
just data
is when you do something like this it
makes a copy of this entire object
and it places that copy
into well in this example into the
vector
and there are two separate pieces of
data
charles still exists out here and then
we got a copy of charles in here
but in this case they are still the same
piece of data because it's the shared
pointer so
uh if we were to
change charles's details from any of
these sources that own him it would
update the control block
and
basically propagate all its updates
across all the owners which is another
nice really nice feature
because what if uh
well
let's take a look at something here
well anytime we say name let's also
say the ref count
so we'll put another area in right here
where we're going to go
whatever the shared pointer is
use count
there we go and that is a function
and there we go so now we can see the
use count there let's just copy that
down here as well
and we should see that increment from
one to two
charles one charles two yeah i didn't
put any spaces or anything but as you
can see those are a little ref count and
say the kennel makes some changes
so we take this let's take the front dog
here in this case now normally he would
probably have some some all kinds of
kennel special functions to do things
but in this case we're just going to go
change something about him maybe we can
say
he lost a pound
so we'll bring him down to 50. well
weight
equals 50. so we can change that value
and now it will change in all cases
that's that's the cool thing so we could
go back to this original one because
we're changing the one at the kennel now
right this is an example
so we're gonna print out this original
one again
down here
except this time we're gonna go wait
and we should see
that we get 50.
now this is just to show that anything
can edit it yeah we got 50
rather than the original 51.
so that shows that it propagates across
all of them that's how you do it
all right now let's just throw in some
additional ownership
say um
maybe there was an original humor human
owner
so we'll put the dog there as well and
we just do another pushback
that's all you do
to get it in this case
we have dogs owned
slightly different name
maybe we keep it the same
but now the humans gonna have their own
copy as well
and we should see the use count increase
from that well it's gonna be human
dot dogs because that's the variable
name
then we need to get the first one on the
vector
so front
the reason i'm using these vectors of
course is
well you know just so they can hold
multiple but we're only using the first
one and then you can see now we now have
three references and any of them can
make changes
it might not make sense and for any of
these to make changes like the human
probably isn't going to make changes to
it while it's at the kennel
and stuff like that
but this is a shared ownership case and
sharing the ownership of stuff like this
doesn't really make much sense that's
kind of personal to the dog so maybe it
would make more sense to design this in
a way that had something like these were
private
but anyone can changes i don't know
you decide
how you want to go and reason about that
okay so maybe the poor pup ends up at
the vet
so we put him here too
and we can
say the same info except now this is
that
very similar structs but now it's owned
by four different other objects
and we can still
do the c out
or do the console out and get the name
and the use count and we should now have
four and as long as something owns it
or something has it
it's fine
because what if we do something like
this what if we make the kennel go into
scope
but then go out of scope so when kennel
goes out of scope it's going to
deallocate
all of its stuff
so we should see
the first instantiation use count one
use count two use count three they'll go
out of scope and then we should see a
new use count three
because the kennel is going to destruct
and we do see that so it is
properly
decrementing when one is no longer used
but the dog is going to exist as long as
something is using it
if nothing's using it that's the only
time it's going to fully
destruct
and you don't necessarily need to make
it go out of scope to do this
you can also just
use the release keyword
say
maybe you know once the dog
it initially gets checked in
and then it gets sent somewhere else so
maybe this would be like the check-in
right
let's just make a theoretical workflow
example for like someone that's managing
a dog going to the kennel and vet and
back to its human
so this would be like the check-in
because we gotta create it we could in
theory create it on the first pushback
with like a make shared right here
that would be fine too
but maybe once we're done with the
check-in
we want to
remove it after we give it
somewhere else so let's let's wait on
the human
yeah we'll give it we'll we'll say
yeah let's make sure we we tag the owner
so we'll make the owner right
away and then we'll give it
to the kennel and then also maybe it's
getting sent to the vet but down here we
say look the human has
given the pup up don't i wouldn't
recommend but what would you do here is
human
dogs dot front
dot reset
and that would reset the first
doge
essentially setting that pointer back to
to null
you could also do a pop back in this
case
on
this thing
and that should essentially do the same
thing because it'll remove it from the
vector and de-allocate it which will
decrease the reference count
but if you want it to stay on the vector
like maybe they're replacing it with
another dot you still use front
and then you would reset
oh it's dot reset because we're using
the shared pointer
and after that the human no longer
has it has a dog there but we could give
it a new dog
and
we do so
why well we didn't pop the back of that
so there's still data there
it just needs to be something else
so we could go
make shared
of a new dog
oh this is pretty weird and i would not
recommend doing this
this particular way
because it's really confusing code but
it works
because that's how it's designed
because at this point well the human has
a dog with no name no age no wait
nothing
so we'd probably want to do something
like this first make another dog
we'll call him a chat
maybe maybe he's a slightly older dog
and a much smaller dog
a measly
uh 22 pound dog who's hunger always
hungry because it's chihuahua or
something
and at this point
we would go
like so just to sign it there
and maybe we're done with this
instantiation one
oh we gotta make sure we actually go dog
two here
once we give it to the human
we'll delete it from this allocator
so you can use this in type like a
factory type pattern pretty well too
where you make something you pass it off
and then you get rid of the original one
by doing reset but it won't go out of
scope because now the human owns it it's
not going to fully de-allocate
until
we release it here too so at this point
there's definitely a lot more i could
say
but it'd probably be worth going to look
at the documentation and if there's a
lot of questions i will make a part two
so it would be good idea
to go to this webpage
and
have a gander at all the uh member
functions
and basically what you can do
now we only used a few
we used reset
we kind of used the equals with our
pushback was essentially an equals in
this case it's not technically right
but it's it's basically what we were
doing
okay there's a lot of other little
functions here you can see
you don't necessarily need to use them
all
we used make shared
you can see there's even more stuff you
can you can set
how it calls the deleter
which is pretty interesting
and might be necessary in some cases
but in general you probably won't have
to touch that let's see what they do in
their example
i feel like i've went through this
before
okay they used some threads and some
bass and derived classes
and what are they doing here they make a
shared pointer the bass
oh they're just showing you can do
inheritance type polymorphism stuff with
them too
where you can make a base type
and do a make shared with its derived
so that's kind of cool
shared ownership between three threads
and released
okay so i guess that's a pretty
interesting use as well you can share
them out to threads
and also i found another pretty
decent write-up of these
over on the microsoft docs here we are
so these are like the main two sources i
was looking at
um
when i learned these and stuff
originally pretty nice little uh
explanation there
and i'm not sure about their example
what are they doing they got a
they got a media asset with a destructor
virtual instructor okay
in a song which is a media asset as an
artist and a title
and just a little constructor there
for that
and then they have a photo which is also
a media asset and this one is a date
location subject
and all i need to do is implement the
destructor it looks like
or if they want
this isn't pure virtual i don't think no
okay
right
i don't know what is equal to fault here
i'm used to seeing equal zero for pure
virtual
i'll have to look that up afterwards or
someone can leave a comment if you want
but i'll probably looked it up by then
all right and then they
do some examples let's look at their
example one
they make a song with that as the artist
and this is the title
okay and they're using auto so they
don't have to
do the the whole write up we could use
auto
in all these cases right here
because they will figure it out
just a way to save a little bit
and looks like they make another song
and they use the
new expression
so basically i guess they're trying to
point out here you should always use
make shared if possible you can use new
as well
but it says okay but slightly less
efficient
oh just it doesn't create
a named variable for other code access
okay so i guess if we're relating that
to our example here
we could do that in any of
these
instead of having this whole check-in
thing
we could just go
new
dog
and i guess
we can't just do new because
this doesn't want
oh wait that should work
i don't know
i'm confusing myself at this point i
think it's
possibly messed up because of this down
here
but
you probably get the point
or
maybe we can't do that in a push back
maybe we need to use in place back if
we're doing that
i guess we could try it real quick
okay let's
let's get rid of all this code
and it's no longer going to know what
dog one is
so maybe we have to pass it in from the
human dogs
all right
ideally you'd have some kind of
algorithm to find the right dog and not
just pass it the front one but let's
just try what happens here when we put
new dog
uh
it doesn't like it well we kind of
should be
using this here it doesn't know
what dog one is anymore
uh based on this use count
we'll just put human in all of these
although really i should be using the
one from the proper one but since
they're shared data it will actually be
fine unless this human one goes out of
scope then you know that that's bad okay
let's just correct it
so we don't run into problems later
okay and we're
missing they got this one here
so it's saying we could go
new dog like that
that doesn't seem to work what are they
doing different in their example
i don't know they just have an actual
constructor i guess is the main thing
huh yeah this according to their oh no
no what am i thinking we want this like
like so
not an equals it doesn't have an
assignment so okay we can do it that way
so this isn't going to work
basically because
this doesn't use it as a constructor but
in place back
does use it as a constructor so that
will work
here
just like here
because i as i was saying earlier well
it's not technically correct doing the
pushback is sort of like doing an equals
uh that variable equals so you can't
pass a constructor in the equals just
like we saw down here that's just the c
plus plus thing
and don't quote me on that because
that's just how i think of it because
that's how it tends to work i don't know
if that's a hundred percent correct that
we can initialize with
that and then set it later so if it's no
pointer you can set it later if it's
reset
if you call that dot reset you can set
it later
and they have more examples i think this
episode's gone on long enough
at this point
but just we'll fly through the last few
things real quick
so initializing one with sp2 increments
ref count yes that makes sense at this
point also increments if you set it
equals so make another one
and then they make another one and they
null pointer and then they do a swap
so they take sp1 and swap it
sp2
so sp1 was beetles they swap it with the
lady gaga song so they should just be
switched around
initializes with another shared pointer
swaps the pointers
as well as the reference counts
so that's pretty handy it's going to be
pretty efficient to do
swap when that makes sense
and it looks like you can use remove
copy if to make some little uh remove
algorithm or function if you need to
and it works
just fine there on a vector so we could
that's essentially what we should design
in this sort of setup in the long run
and stuff like that to help manage it
properly and make sure
it works as we were kind of talking
about you don't want the vet to
pass it off to the wrong person or
whatever you know
or
or be
i don't know
there's there's some great way to put it
but i can't think of it all right
now just goes through them all
example four
what do we got here
dynamic pointer cast static pointer cast
const pointer cast to cast a shared
pointer these functions resemble dynamic
static okay so you can basically just do
casts with them now casts are typically
doing uh
dynamics and static and const casts
i personally try to avoid them if
possible
but you never know when you might need
to do it to
get around some weird
thing
so it looks like you can do it with
shared pointers they just got their own
special
functions to do that
that's the whole point with that one
example 5 is just a wall of text there's
no code
all right i'm not going to read all that
but i think it basically saying stuff
we've already learned for the most part
in example six
overloads various comparison operators
okay so you can do comparisons
so you make two songs
they're exactly the same although
they're
not the same shared pointer right
same name same
uh song
but they're not they're not passing each
other they're both doing a new operation
so
they are different although they have
the same names i think is what the point
they're getting here
then they create another two unrelated
shared pointers
song one and song two
and then
you can basically check for a quality
which they're doing right here
they're showing what comparison they're
doing
they're setting the c out mode to bull
alpha so it'll say true or false instead
of zero or one and then they're doing
the comparison and then they're doing
another comparison
so we got a less than operation and an
equals operation
uh what would that spit out
it says unrelated pointers are never
equal
is this is p1 less than p2 i i'm not
sure what that would come back as
but they're not equal so it could be
true
but this one should be false
because they are different this is
basically going to compare
the memory locations of the control
object
so it's not going to care about these
names it's going to care about hey is
this the same control block yes or no
and this comparison here i'm not 100
sure how the less than is going to work
it's probably going to go off memory
address so if one happens to be at a
lower location
i'm not sure i'm not sure on that last
one but the equals one is pretty
consistent
all right related sharepoint instances
are always equals so they make another
one they give it p2
p2 and p3 this should be true
that's why they're different
uh
variables they're the same shared
pointer instance
all right hope that all makes sense let
me know if you have questions down below
thanks for watching and special shout
out to the patrons of this channel for
making
these episodes possible
[Music]
peace out you guys
[Music]
um
[Music]
you